we've earned and collected now about
three hundred thousand dollars from
YouTube Secrets it is just on Amazon
distributed through Amazon through all
their self-publishing tools that's the
physical book in the ebook the audiobook
is generated another fifty thousand
deeper than that though what about
clients leads people that know like and
Trust You discovery of the YouTube
channel all of the above YouTube Secrets
has actually generated millions of
dollars if you think about clients leads
and there's some direct tracking but I
think the other way to think about it is
brand lift Authority awareness that
comes from writing a book when the
perception of your brand is strengthened
and when more leads clients and
awareness comes in if you have products
and services which we do at think media
then that leads to more money being
earned in fact what that free class that
Chandler and I are co-hosting is about
is how to write and publish a book and
how to add six figures in Revenue to
your business this year by publishing a
book